Gorehounds agree: It's a great time to be
a horror fan.
And though 2020 promises its fair share of
dark delights, it'd be a shame if you missed
any of the macabre horror highlights of 2019.
Prepare to scream.
"Ooh - scary movie…"
The wide open spaces of the American frontier
are often romanticized by classic westerns,
but The Wind recognizes the terror and existential
dread at the heart of those vast, desolate
lands.
The debut film from director Emma Tammi follows
a tough frontierswoman named Lizzy, played
by Caitlin Gerard.
She's clearly haunted by all the emptiness
that surrounds her - not to mention the ever-present,
chilling wind howling across the plains.
Despite reassurances from her husband, Lizzy
becomes increasingly convinced that some sort
of demonic presence is tormenting her.
But is something supernatural really to blame,
or is the root of all her horror simply loneliness?
It's a question that's bound to haunt anyone
who braves this atmospheric slow burn of a
horror film.
The Hole in the Ground is a thoroughly unnerving
movie.
In his feature film debut, Irish writer and
director Lee Cronin tells the story of a mother
and son hoping to escape their troubled past
by moving to a remote countryside village.
Needless to say, trouble eventually finds
them there, too.
"Mom look out!"
"It's not your boy!"
There's something quite disturbing about their
new home… especially that enormous sinkhole
in the nearby woods.
The boy's inevitable encounter with the titular
hole in the ground leaves his mother feeling
rather uneasy - and rightfully so.
Sure, there's no shortage of horror films
with creepy kids running amok, but Cronin
handles the material in a way that feels both
modern and fresh.
As The Guardian writes in its glowing review,
"[The Hole in the Ground] always finds new,
invariably cinematic ways to nudge us towards
its final leap into the abyss.
Cronin feels like a real find for our especially
insecure moment."
A horror movie doesn't need to take itself
seriously in order to be great.
Take Crawl, for instance.
This throwback creature feature stars a bunch
of killer alligators chasing a father and
his daughter after their Florida home is flooded
in a Category 5 hurricane.
"Get down!"
No, it's not a particularly sophisticated
premise - and that's part of what makes the
film so great.
Critics wholeheartedly agreed, with Slate
writing that
"It’s fast, efficient, crisply directed,
and delivers on the promised alligator thrills
[...]. Those B-movie values feel especially
refreshing."
It seems like a straightforward revenge thriller
at first, but The Perfection has all sorts
of tricks up its sleeve… and it takes some
extremely dark turns as it hops wildly from
genre to genre.
Is it a body horror film?
A psychological thriller?
It's both... and a jet-black comedy to boot.
The Perfection also happens to be preposterously
gross… and yes, that's a ringing endorsement.
The film involves Charlotte, a former musical
prodigy played by Allison Williams.
You already suspect she's up to no good when
she seduces the school's current lead cellist
Elizabeth, played to perfection by Logan Browning.
"Am I the luckiest man in the world?
I don't even drink and I feel giddy drunk.
My two most perfect students together."
Before you know it, the film morphs into a
sadistic, gore-smeared spectacular that's
full of nasty surprises.
Adventurous critics were quick to praise the
film, with Rolling Stone commenting that
"In its own blood-splattered, limb-lopping
way, it may be a particularly perfect thriller
for this moment."
Ready or Not got a bit lost in the shuffle
when it hit theaters in summer 2019, and that's
really too bad: This well-crafted horror film
is a black comedy and slasher flick rolled
into one, and it really deserves to be seen.
At every turn, Ready or Not manages to be
funny, intelligent, and incredibly well-acted.
The premise centers around a young woman named
Grace - played by Samara Weaving.
She's forced to play a deadly game of hide-and-seek
upon marrying into a wealthy and highly eccentric
family.
As it turns out, that family evidently signed
a deal with the devil several years back,
and the pact requires that they sacrifice
a newly-joined member of the clan.
That newly-joined member is, of course, Grace
… but let it suffice to say, she's not going
without a fight.
The majority of critics loved this sly and
subversive film, with Vulture proclaiming,
"The movie is a vicious, richly funny, and
artfully brutal tale that places Weaving’s
performance as its gravitational center."
Set in the dark underbelly of the Los Angeles
art scene, Bliss follows the exploits of a
struggling young painter who is clearly at
the very end of her rope.
This self-indulgent, self-destructive soul
eagerly engulfs every drug under the sun in
search of artistic inspiration.
Well, she eventually finds her muse - but
at a considerable cost.
Aided by a seriously vampiric gal-pal, she
quickly spirals into a gruesome and gory nightmare
of her own making.
The results are thoroughly disgusting… but
is it art?
"I don't know.
Something came over me.
And it all just started pouring out of me.
I don't even remember doing it."
Bliss is a no-holds-barred assault on the
senses - and in the best possible way.
This film is so visually out there that it's
just begging to become a future cult classic.
The A.V.
Club aptly writes that
"[Bliss] approaches its aesthetic with a straight-faced
intensity, pummeling the viewer with [...] violent
bursts of montage until you feel like maybe
you might have been dosed somehow on your
way into the theater."
In Sweetheart, Kiersey Clemons plays a traumatized
young woman who manages to survive a devastating
shipwreck… only to wind up in another deadly
situation.
After washing ashore on a deserted island,
she's left to her own devices with limited
resources - and must do whatever she can to
survive.
To make matters worse, a mysterious and malevolent
creature seems to be on the loose.
With a runtime under 90 minutes, Sweetheart
is a brisk and brutal chiller that dazzled
lots of critics.
Vulture clearly loved the unconventional film,
writing that:
"[Sweetheart is] an ingenious affair, a no-nonsense
monster movie that uses its limitations effectively
and tells its story cinematically."
Over the years we've seen more than a few
horror films riffing on Frankenstein … but
Depraved is really its own undead beast.
If you've ever wanted to see a zombie shamble
his way through New York nightlife, this is
the film for you.
But you better have a strong stomach.
The mad doctor in this case is an ex-army
medic with a severe case of PTSD.
His creation, Adam, is thoughtful and intelligent.
It says a lot that this ungodly creature is
probably the most empathetic character in
the film.
Rest assured, there's enough gore on display
to satisfy even the most hardcore horror fans,
but the best thing about Depraved is that
it cuts way deeper than your average chiller.
"In my dreams I'm someone else."
"I owe you something like a normal life."
No wonder the critical consensus on Rotten
Tomatoes raves that
"Depraved jolts a familiar monster back to
life with a potent blend of timely themes
and old-school chills."
Hagazussa: A Heathen's Curse is anything but
a mainstream horror film - but this full-throttle
creepshow really manages to get under your
skin.
In the 15th century Alps, a young woman has
been deemed a witch by the townsfolk… and
honestly, you might be able to see their point.
She spends her days hopelessly alone, with
only her infant child and her beloved goats
there to keep her company.
But when the townspeople turn against her
in a violent manner, she descends into a state
of hopeless madness.
The results are both fascinating and repulsive.
Hagazussa is beautifully shot, without a doubt.
More to the point, it features one of the
most horrific finales in recent memory, so
if you check it out - and you should - consider
yourself warned.
Neil Jordan's Greta is an outrageous and darkly
campy thriller - but it certainly begins innocently
enough.
Chloë Grace Moretz plays Frances, a recent
transplant to New York City who's struggling
with the recent death of her mother.
When she discovers a handbag left on the subway,
she goes the extra mile to return it to its
owner: The titular Greta, played with insidious
relish by Isabelle Huppert.
Frances becomes fast friends with Greta…
and to say that this French piano teacher
is "eccentric" is the understatement of the
century.
Needless to say, the friendship quickly takes
a turn for the severely sinister.
"People can't keep doing this to me."
Rest assured, this is certainly not the buddy
film of the decade.
But it is delightfully twisted stuff.
In its positive review, Slate commented that
"[Neil] Jordan’s deft control of pace and
tone elevates Greta past mere gimmickry, resulting
in a comic thriller whose goofy humor only
compounds its mastery of suspense."
Set in Mexico and focused squarely on the
country's violent drug wars, the dark fantasy
Tigers Are Not Afraid is certainly not for
the faint of heart.
At the center of the story is a little girl
named Estrella, whose mother has suddenly
disappeared with no explanation whatsoever.
In the hopes of calming Estrella after gunshots
are heard outside her school, a teacher gives
her three pieces of chalk … and tells her
that they can grant her three wishes.
As Estrella adjusts to her bizarre new life
and falls in with a roving league of fellow
orphans, she starts to believe those three
wishes might be entirely real.
But make no mistake: This isn't some lofty
exercise in magical realism.
It's a bleak, unsparing, and totally terrifying
film that critics absolutely adored.
In its effusive review, Consequence of Sound
proclaimed,
"The film is replete with unforgettable images,
stellar performances all up and down the cast,
and genuinely original and thoughtful revisions
of expected tropes."
Little Monsters dares to answer the burning
question that's never far from our minds:
What would happen if a bunch of kindergarteners
found themselves smack dab in the middle of
a zombie outbreak during a field trip?
In order to keep her kids from getting scared,
a wholesome schoolteacher - played wonderfully
by Lupita Nyong'o - tries to make the kids
believe it's all just a fun game.
"It is a bit scary."
"What do we do when we're scared?
What's a song we can sing?"
Meanwhile, Josh Gad plays insufferable kids'
show personality Teddy McGiggle, who soon
enough falls victim to the outbreak… and
starts looking at children in a whole new
way.
Little Monsters proves that a horror film
doesn't have to be deadly serious in order
to be incredible.
It's also been a huge hit with critics, currently
boasting a 93% Fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Any child of the '80s or '90s knows Scary
Stories to Tell in the Dark.
In this iconic and creepy series, author Alvin
Schwartz gathered up the most eerie and unsettling
short tales from the annals of urban legends
and folklore.
The film adaptation brings several of those
stories to the silver screen in a way that
will be frightening for children and adults
alike.
"Some people believe if we repeat stories
often enough, they become real."
The consensus on Rotten Tomatoes speaks for
itself, claiming that
"[Scary Stories To Tell in the Dark] opens
a creepy gateway into horror for younger genre
enthusiasts."
This is a frightening and cleverly constructed
horror film that delivers plenty of jump scares
without going overboard.
You've heard of a waking nightmare, right?
Well, Ari Aster's Midsommar plays out more
like a waking daydream, and the results are
fantastically frightening.
"What time is it?"
"9 p.m."
"That can't be right.
The sky is blue."
The fact that many of the film's horror sequences
unfold in broad daylight certainly doesn't
shield the characters from the dangers at
hand.
Far from it.
This is Aster's followup to his 2018 debut
- the instant classic Hereditary - and it
involves a young shell-shocked woman named
Dani.
She's just endured a horrific family tragedy,
and her aloof boyfriend Christian certainly
isn't helping matters.
In fact, he clearly wants out of the relationship.
Things go from bad to worse when Dani tags
along with Christian and his pompous, pseudo-intellectual
group of friends, who are heading off to a
remote Swedish village.
The occasion is an ultra-rare, ultra-mysterious
midsummer festival.
As we learn more about the eerie pagan rituals
on display, the film lurches towards a druggy,
deranged conclusion that puts even The Wicker
Man to shame.
This is folk horror at its finest.
Jordan Peele's Get Out was an immediate sensation
when it premiered in 2017, and rightly so:
Its blend of unconventional scares and arch
social commentary was a brilliant balancing
act, and the film is impossible to get out
of your head once you've seen it.
Well, Get Out certainly wasn't a fluke, as
anyone who's seen Us can attest.
The seemingly simple story involves a family
that's being inexplicably tormented by their
own evil doppelgangers during a summer vacation
in Santa Cruz, California.
"Who are you people?"
"It's us."
Of course, you should brace yourself for plenty
of twists and turns along the way.
The film was widely praised, with The New
Yorker's Nathan Lane writing,
"Us is political filmmaking of the most spirited
sort, and it sets up quite a fight: the Hydes
come to visit the Jekylls, and the Jekylls
hit back.
Whom you cheer for, in the long run, is up
to you."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.